well I guess we're stuck here for a bit
you're a kitty I'm your fucking kitty
cat well whatever the hell my line was
I'm glad I'm not the only one missing
yeah well I guess while we're stuck here
with the why don't you forget that line
I guess we're stuck here for a bit why
is that so difficult now the mental race
your name saw it see me so I thought you
really laughs I have to did now how long
did that take to sail about minute less
than a minute I guess right good this is
use me I'm sorry these lines are too
long yeah that was to my eyes needing a
like okay why didn't I write a turkey
career right
Bueller dry eyes sorry so they hook him
up to a lie detector squid story book
all that goes off but advice all right
not hot but sometimes it can make one
lose once moment I'm gonna be testing
Malcolm on is the I ha ha ha the squid
can sense your feelings
July's Kyle this is argued I'm Jewish me
consent you feeling oh that's gross Rose
are you
oh just holes your child yes yes it
looks huge it's huge it's really shitty
okay well it sounds like it's good and I
am still looking each other all right
yeah how can we talk and you look
different today you're particularly well
animated this morning have you done
something with your face
perhaps some makeup we're gonna be five
more times the next 24 hours
excellent will you be as well animated
then as you are now
probably not well damn it
characters that just weren't that
interesting and you couldn't get sucked
in too you see one going with this yeah
um make it a pizza we use Jerry wrenches
for the badges they're not exactly the
brightest stars no solar system okay and
then I didn't read your lines coming
really funny just think of something
there's only so many places I can put
this nothing moves their hair out before
they die I like do so fucking done I
don't care it looks cool the hairs in
front of it I'm done okay but more hair
in front a way out okay Oh careful okay